[Musique]
une table ronde pour conclure une
semaine de sensibilisation à la liberté
d'expression ce 15 novembre pour un
réfugié politique participer à
l'événement organisé à la commanderie de
saint quentin en yvelines marlène
schiappa étaient présentes à
vélizy-villacoublay la ministre délégué
chargé de la citoyenneté répondait à
l'invitation de jean noël barrot député
de la 2e circonscription qu'une centaine
de personnes étaient présentes la
campagne pour le congrès les
républicains continuent après xavier
bertrand c'est valérie pécresse qui
tenait un meeting une étape à domicile
pour l'actuel président de la région ile
de france la ville de la verrière de
faciliter la concertation avec les
habitants sur l'avenir du bois de
l'étang aile inauguré le 16 novembre une
maison de projets les habitants sont
invités à partager leurs habits depuis
le mois d'octobre pour pallier la
désertification médicale de la commune
la ville de plaisir a fait le choix
d'installer une borne à la maison des
familles flora tristan pour qu'un maître
des téléconsultations la semaine
européenne pour l'emploi des personnes
handicapées se tient jusqu'au 21
novembre une catégorie fortement touché
ces deux fois supérieure au reste de la
population et puis le 18 novembre
c'était la journée nationale de lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire la team
anti-harcèlement du lycée battre quant à
rambouillet a organisé plusieurs
rendez-vous pour sensibiliser
[Musique]